in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused
for ours i'm going to say for that 150
horsepower class
that would be our bread and butter
i'm going to say 90 of the tractors we
sell are in that class
on that thing there and
we've got to the point where
we'll get out we'll demonstrate
you know uh if we have somebody go down
we'll run them a tractor loan one for
the time being to keep them going
on that
and then all of a sudden they come back
in hey
calf check was better than what we had
we
we know we need one we got a tough
winter coming and we planted the seed
and it came back
the
the combines and the four wheel drives
that'd be a very nice market to be in
but you look the hours these guys are
putting on the machines how that's
changed in the last 20 years uh they buy
one of those that
they might they might not have buy
another one for another 20 years and
these smaller ones we can get more guys
rolling into them and if we can
get the customer just
give them the
reputation where they need to trade more
often we can keep our business going and
our part of the country is guys will buy
them and run for 10 or 15 years instead
of trading after five
and we would like to get to the point
where you can get them to roll them more
often to keep them current keep them
under warranty and to realize how the
technology is changing not only for
their benefit but for ours also
in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused